well fast fit body sculpting the
sponsors of this next segment can help
you get rid of unwanted weight and
joining us to tell us more is the
founder doug zuko hi doug
hello good afternoon thank you so much
for joining us can you tell us a little
bit about body sculpting and what it is
well body sculpting is a reduction of
fat on the body so at fast fit we focus
on fat loss not necessarily weight loss
but we want the body to lose fat
and after the sculpting i think a big
question everyone has is will that
weight stay off or how do you maintain
it
well that's a great question so i like
to tell stories so i'm going to tell you
a story one of my favorite clients her
name's lenoir and i think we have a
picture of her
but lenora came to us with her husband
stephen and she did a consultation
and
lenora is now down almost 39 pounds of
pure fat
her husband steven was a little
skeptical like i'm skeptical steven so
he didn't do it at all right away but
then he did later and right now he's
down 28 pounds of pure fat and lenora
has a great story she tried out for the
wnba dance uh
dance team the aces
and she made the cut so congratulations
lenore oh my gosh that's so exciting
congratulations to her and you know you
mentioned if someone is maybe skeptical
about the procedure just wants to learn
more how would you say that fast fit is
different from other procedures
well fastfit we focus on the natural way
of reducing fat on the body so not only
subcutaneous fat but visceral fat and
visceral fats that hidden fat we have in
our midsection under the muscle
so visceral fats that dangerous fat we
don't want to have and fast fits one of
the only technologies can actually
reduce visceral fat also
and if people are wondering if they're
qualified to do this what's the process
like do you have to come in for a
consultation or kind of run us through
that
we make it simple just come in and talk
to us you know when we sit down with you
hear your goals what we say will make
sense to everyone i hear a lot of people
say well i was nervous about coming in
or just a little afraid no need to be
afraid come on in we're going to do a
body analysis a general health
assessment and we're going to explain to
you how this is different how this is
going to work for you
and if people are a little nervous or
afraid does the process hurt or is it
quick and you know how would you kind of
sell them that you know what this this
is worth it
it's actually pain not to be painless
it's enjoyable so basically it's very
spa-like you just lay down relax for
about 15 minutes and then
go for a walk and we just lose that fat
well you can't beat that doug thank you
so much you can call now for 50 off and
the first 20 callers will be part of the
special offer the locations are on your
screen here summerlin centennial west
sahara and henderson you can call 1-800
fast fit or visit
fastfitbodysculpting.com
las vegas now we'll be right back